[Music]
do you know who was the first person to
hit a net worth of 200 billion dollars
if you follow the billionaires list
closely you'd probably guess jeff bezos
or elon musk but one financier named
bill browder has been claiming that this
title actually goes to vladimir putin
who apparently hit the mark nearly seven
years ago this is quite ironic given
that its official presidential salary is
only 8.8 million rubles per year or
about 130 000
even if he were to save his entire
salary every year it would take him 2
million years to hit 200 billion even
with compound growth of 10 per year it
would take him 125 years but i don't
think any of us are stupid enough to
believe that the presidential
compensation is putin's true source of
wealth in fact the reason that he's not
listed on forbes or bloomberg is because
he's believed to have sourced most of
his wealth through illegal avenues
vladimir putin 17 years of the most
powerful man in the world so here's how
vladimir putin managed to accumulate 200
billion dollars and to become the modern
day of russia
taking a look back vladimir putin was
born on october 7th 1952 in leningrad
ussr or modern-day st petersburg russia
he was the youngest of three children
born to vladimir spirit donovak putin
and maria ivanovnaputina putin didn't
have much experience getting along with
the siblings though as both of them had
passed away before he was even born one
of his older brothers victor had
actually passed away during the siege of
leningrad when the nazis occupied the
city for nearly three years and victor
was just one of one million civilian and
military casualties during the siege you
would think that such an experience
would leave a sour taste in the family's
mouth but putin's family was actually
extremely patriotic in fact many of his
family members served political and
military roles his grandmother for
instance was a personal chef for
vladimir lenin and joseph stalin
similarly two of his uncles gave their
lives on the eastern front during world
war ii and putin's father was a
conscript in the soviet navy who served
until he was severely wounded given that
putin was born well after world war ii
he didn't have to experience any of
these events but i'm sure his family
told him all about it anyway putin would
end up attending school number 193 which
was a local school near his home at
school one of his favorite tasks was
reading books about karl marx and
vladimir lenin and as he grew older he
also started to spend some time learning
[ __ ] and judo moving on to high school
putin would attend st petersburg high
school and one of the most valuable
things he learned there was how to speak
german he would later perfect these
skills and he's thought to be quite
fluent today
anyway moving into college putin would
spend five years in leningrad state
university and earned his law degree in
1975. while at university putin became
friends with the business law professor
named antoi softcheck who will become
quite important later on in the story
around the same time putin was forced to
join the communist party of the soviet
union it's not clear how exactly putin
felt about this when he was a kid he was
one of the only kids who didn't join the
young pioneer organization which is
exactly what you think it is also putin
would go on to claim that communism is
quote a blind alley far away from the
mainstream of civilization so i'm not
sure if putin would have joined the
communist party out of free will
but he definitely was not going to leave
out of free will and that brings us into
putin's days at the kgb
after graduating from las cola putin
enrolled in the kgb and started his
training if you're not familiar with the
kgb it was the soviet union's
intelligence agency or basically their
fbi cia putin's first role after
training was within the second chief
directorate which primarily focused on
collecting counterintelligence this
didn't last long though as he would soon
be transferred over to the first chief
directorate where he was tasked with
monitoring foreigners and consulates
putin completed such menial tasks for
nearly a decade until september of 1984
when he was invited to complete further
training at the yuri andropov redbanner
institute after this additional training
putin was sent to dresden east germany
which is where he got his reputation for
being a badass kgb spine the story goes
that putin worked as an undercover
translator and that he was involved in
crazy events for example one story
suggests that putin helped protect the
integrity of the soviet union during the
collapse of the berlin wall apparently
he saved the files at the soviet
cultural center and he burned the secret
kgb files located in dresden but many
journalists suggest that this is not
what happened at all masha gessen for
example claims that even in dresden
putin was mainly limited to menial tasks
masha suggests that putin spent most of
his time collecting press clippings most
of which were useless to the ussr
even one of putin's kgb colleagues
vladimir gusaltsev agrees that they
didn't accomplish anything too
praiseworthy some other journalists
suggest that this is just a cover to
hide how involved putin was with the kgb
but most of the evidence would suggest
otherwise for example remember how putin
burned a bunch of fouls at dresden well
germany was able to retrieve most of the
important files that he apparently
burned also it's not like putin cleverly
left the kgb right before the collapse
of the ussr the kgb actually forced him
to resign from active service after
dresden because they felt that they
couldn't trust his allegiance back in
leningrad putin continued to help with
kgb recruiting but as soon as the coup
against the soviet president began putin
fully resigned from the kgb on august
20th 1991 and the ussr would end up
collapsing just a few months later
now that putin was out of a job he
decided to rekindle his friendship with
the professor from college and toy's
object and this couldn't have been
better timing you see with the fall of
the soviet union sobcheck was trying to
secure a position in politics putin
helped subject throughout the campaign
trail and he quickly became one of
subject's most trusted allies sobchak
would go on to win the election and he
became the first democratically elected
mayor of st petersburg as gratitude for
all of putin's help on the campaign
trail sobcheck would appoint putin as
his advisor on international affairs
while this was a great start for putin
in politics it didn't take him long to
leave his object in the dust on june 28
1991 putin was promoted the head of
electoral relations at the mayor's
office and this is when he would spark
up his first controversy it was revealed
that putin had used his powers to
improve the export of 93 million dollars
worth of medals in return for foreign
food aid that never came
after the news broke investigators
actually recommended that putin be fired
but this never unfolded because putin
simply had too much public support
american presidents often struggled to
crack 50 percent above a rating
threshold but putin has crushed this
milestone throughout his entire career
in fact even with the ukraine situation
putin's approval rating currently sits
at 71
from an outside perspective it this
might be a bit confusing as putin often
comes off as a corrupt merciless ruler
but most russians wouldn't want anyone
else in putin's place
the key to putin's popularity is twofold
the first reason is that ever since the
soviet union dissolved the financial
situation of the average russian has
exponentially improved in fact the
average monthly income has grown nearly
100x now it's not clear how much of this
is actually due to putin and how much is
simply due to a more capitalistic
economy but a lot of russians associate
putin's rise to power with their own
financial rise leading them to pledge
their support the second reason for
putin's overwhelming support is that he
was the strong leader that many russians
felt they needed in the 1990s many
russians felt that their power and
dominance on the world team had fallen
off a cliff ever since the 1960s and
given pune's intense patriotism and iron
fist it seemed like he was the right man
to return russia to its former glory and
if you don't believe me just take a look
at 130 000 people singing the russian
national anthem with putin
[Music]
clearly this is not a guy that's lacking
public support
anyway putin leverages public support to
continue moving up the political ladder
in 1996 he was promoted to deputy chief
of the presidential property management
directorate two years later he was
promoted to first deputy chief of staff
of the presidential executive office and
in 1999 the president of russia boris
yeltsin chose putin to be the prime
minister of russia and when yeltsin
stepped down from being president he
nominated putin to be a successor putin
would go on to win the 2000 election
garnering 53 of the vote and his
popularity has only grown since for
example he won the 2018 election with
76.69
of the votes to put that in perspective
the only american president who won a
larger percentage of the popular vote
for james monroe and george washington
with such overwhelming support it's
clear that putin isn't going anywhere
anytime soon
so we've covered how putin got to the
top politically but how did putin get to
the top financially after leaving the
kgb putin says that he considered
becoming a taxi driver to earn extra
money so things were looking quite bleak
but today he's potentially the richest
person in the world so what happened
well like all billionaires his primary
source of wealth is acid starting with
stakes and companies putin is speculated
to have massive stakes in a handful of
oil giants this includes a 37 percent
stake in circuit nephigus a 4.5 stake in
god's prom and at least a 75 stake in
gunver all these companies are extremely
private and some of them have even
rejected the notion that putin is a
shareholder but critics argue that this
is just an attempt to cover up his
involvement with these companies after
all it's highly unlikely that putin paid
for these takes the more likely scenario
is that he was given these stakes in
return for political favors whether that
be either regulation or government
contracts similarly putin also has a
vast portfolio of real estate holdings
including 20 different palaces and
villas and we're not talking about real
estate worth of tens of millions or even
hundreds of millions some of these
holdings individually clock in at over
one billion dollars putin of course
denies owning these estates and it may
be true that he doesn't directly own
these properties but it's speculated
that putin owns all these stakes and
properties through various proxies one
of putin's political colleagues
stanislaw belkovsky suggests that putin
is worth at least 40 billion dollars and
in terms of an upper bound he has no
clue so putin is no doubt extremely
wealthy but he doesn't really like to
show off his wealth it seems that his
wallet is more for himself to enjoy as
opposed to something that he shows off
to the media
something that putin is proud to show
off to the world though is his power
by now i'm sure all of you guys are
familiar with the ukrainian situation it
looks like putin is invading ukraine to
quote unquote teach them a lesson many
western countries are starting to place
sanctions on russia and limiting their
abilities but i don't think this really
makes a difference given that putin
fully expected this from the very
beginning
in the meantime pun feels that he is the
wealthiest man not only in russia but
the entire world not in terms of money
though that may also be true but in
terms of trust putin asserts that
russians have entrusted him with the
leadership of russia for over two
decades and that right there will
forever be his greatest wealth are you
guys fans of putin or do you think he's
a douchebag for invading ukraine comment
that down below also drop a like if
you're a fan of the russian national
anthem and of course consider checking
out our international channels to watch
your videos in other languages and
consider subscribing to see more
questions that logically answered but
until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one